alors beaucoup d'entre vous se sont
peut-être demander ce qu'il faisait dans
la scène où ils avaient l'air de
flinguer le sol voilà ils montent à 2
sur une espèce d'engin verticale et ils
ont l'air de balancer une bastos dans le
sol et bien en fait ce qu'ils sont en
train de faire ça s'appelle de la
sismique réflexion c'est très très
utilisée notamment pour cartographier
les fonds marins et pour faire la
géologie des fonds marins la sismique
réflexion du moins tel que tel que je
sais qu'elle est pratiquée c'est en gros
il ya un bateau qui qui est dans une
région dont on veut savoir la géologie
donc le bateau
le problème c'est qu'il ya effectivement
de l'eau entre la géologie et votre
bateau donc vous pouvez pas accéder
directement à la géologie est ce qu'on
fait c'est qu'on n'envoie pas des
plongeurs on envoie des bombes
on envoie des bombes et les bombes vont
exploser les charges explosives ont
explosé et les ondes sismiques qui vont
être envoyés dans l'eau en fête vont
être reflété à la surface de à la
surface de la roche mais aussi certaines
vont pénétrer la roche et vont être
reflété à la prochaine surfaces qu'elles
vont rencontrer c'est à dire au prochain
type de roche et ainsi de suite donc en
fait vous avez une partie des ondes qui
sont reflétées en atteignant la roche
une partie des ondes qui se reflétaient
en atteignant le prochain leader roche
le lit de roche qui est en dessous de la
roche de surface et ensuite vous avez
d'autres roches encore en dessous qui
vont elles aussi refléter les ondes
différemment et ainsi de suite
vous allez obtenir comme ça une
cartographie de votre géologie sous
l'eau
et ça c'est très intéressant parce que
ça permet de voir des choses qu'on ne
peut pas voir du tout à part en faisant
à carottages mais encore une fois les
carottages c'est difficile parce que
tout parce que encore une fois vous avez
vous vous avez cette colonne d'eau qui
vous sépare de la roche donc c'est
difficile de faire un carottage en mer
c'est plus difficile que de faire un
carottage sur terre donc la grande
partie de ce qu'on sait de la géologie
sous marine est due à la sismique
réflexion en grande partie et en et
recoupées avec des données de carottage
c'est à dire des forages qu'on fait dans
les fonds marins mais qui coûte beaucoup
plus cher donc hélas ce qu'ils ont l'air
de faire c'est qu'ils ont l'air de
pratiquer un genre de sismique réflexion
mais avec un fusil donc en fait ils
prennent un fusil ils l'ont monté sur un
genre de d'échafaudages verticale il
tire dans le sol et donc les ondes
sismiques se répercute dans un fossile
de velociraptor qui s'affiche à l'image
sur l'écran qu'on voit ensuite je suis
perplexe
déjà ça n'existe pas vraiment cette
technique ça à peu ils ont peut-être
essayer de la mettre en place et
peut-être qu'ils essayaient de la mettre
en place à l'époque dans les années 90
enfin le livre lui-même a été écrit dans
les années 80 donc si ça se trouve dans
les années 80 90 il essayait de mettre
ça en place
il ya quasiment aucune chance que ça
marche la densité d'un fossile
si vous préférez déjà avec des rayons x
on arrive à peine à voir la différence
entre la densité de certains fossiles et
la densité de la roche qui l'est qui
l'entourent avec des rayons x alors vous
imaginez avec des ondes sismiques les
ondes sismiques à passe au travers du
fossile comme dans du beurre
donc on verrait rien les seuls fossiles
qui à la limite pourrait avoir pourrait
refléter des ondes sismiques se seraient
des faux cils complètement en pyrite
donc en des fossiles qui ont été
complètement remplacé par du minerai de
fer mais faudrait vraiment un gros faux
cils pour pour avoir des détails comme
il arrive à obtenir quoi les détails
qu'ils arrivent à obtenir genre il
arrive à voir les détails du squelette
on en reparlera un petit peu après ils
arrivent à avoir des détails du
squelette s'agit ans j'en doute
j'en doute et de toute façon c'est pas
comme ça qu'est la préservation dans le
montana c'est pas une préservation en
pyrite donc
donc c'est probablement de une technique
inspirée de la sismique réflexion est
probablement dû faire ça a dû faire
plaisir a déjà corner de voir de voir ça
marche et dans un film à défaut de le
voir marcher dans la réalité mais non
cela sismique réflexion je ne pense pas
que ça puisse marcher pour trouver des
fossiles
donc non si ça se compte si ça continue
dans quelques années on aura toujours
besoin de fouiller